let's have a look at where the
candidates declared support is at the
moment we started with that didn't with
the transport secretary Grant chaps has
the backing so far of eight MPS former
Health secretary Jeremy Hunt has 13 or
just hearing there from his uh one of
his campaign team that he has enough to
get through to the second round which
would mean 30. Sajid Javid resigned from
the job last Tuesday he's currently in
the support of 11 MPS declared the
bookie's favorite the former Chancellor
Rishi sunak 38 declared supporters so he
would seem to be well over the line so
far attorney general sowella bravaman
was the first candidate to announce kind
of she has 11 back as the chair of the
Foreign Affairs committee Tom tugenhart
he has 20 supporters so far former
equalities Minister we're still going
kemi badinok she has 13 the
international trade Minister Penny
mordant she has 22 the new Chancellor
Nadim zahawi who started his campaign
yesterday has 14 declared support is the
Home Secretary pretty Patel still
expected to declare at some point she's
apparently got nine declared supporters
and the foreign secretary Liz trust has
15 one more the surprise Contender newly
appointed foreign office minister
Roman chisti has no recorded supporters
as yet Brandon Lewis is here former
Secretary of State for Northern Ireland
would you give him a job
Mr chisty oh look if we're in the
position where champ I mean nobody it's
like the plastic to be picked at
football as I know full well over the
last 10 years or so in government we all
serve the pleasure of the Prime Minister
and that's uh one of these I'm
supporting the demons I want somebody as
prime minister who I believe has got the
right judgment to choose the right team
to lead the country forward and that'll
be a decision for him when the time
comes how many supporters has he got
more than 14 we're I'm very happy that
we'll be able to supply the signatures
and go through the first round of voting
and then obviously things will change
because other colleagues will certainly
not be able to get the the number of
votes that they need and people then
vote for other people we'll see as we go
through rounds two three and four but I
have to say for the feedback we're
getting from colleagues we're confident
we've got a good campaign and I
certainly think we've got a a good
principle a good candidate in the Demons
of Harmony so you've got more than 20.
oh yes yeah do you have more than 30.
we're yes we're very happy that the the
first round yeah through the first two
rounds you think yes okay you say that
you support him because you think that
he's going to be the best person for
prime minister what do you say to those
who say is an absolute Brutus who's
stabbed the prime minister in the back
24 hours 36 hours after getting the job
actually I take it I'd say quite the
opposite that this is somebody who at
the beginning of last week when asked
put Public Service First and accepted we
have to have a Chancellor in the country
and his prime minister asked him to
serve and he took on that role and I
know because a few of us were talking on
Tuesday when when these changes were
going on that there was a still actually
we forget it was still an opportunity to
change the dial get movie on the front
foot potentially actually get out there
with a really good strong Economic
Policy something the demons prime
minister and over the next few days over
the campaign will certainly be outlining
things definitely shifted on Wednesday
and what Nadeem did I think actually it
shows uh the strength of his character
and actually how genuine he is he and
the Prime Minister have known each other
a very very long time and he was one of
those who went to see the Prime Minister
on Wednesday and talk to him about the
situation and was very clear with him
and uh and I think that shows that the
strength of character but he was also
very clear and determined that the
country does need a Chancellor we need
to do everything we can to stabilize the
markets grow our economy and he has a
duty to the country to do that and I
think he's been doing that actually even
over the last few days he's been
balancing the work obviously talking to
colleagues and MPS but still making sure
that he's got the timing to actually
help and support the country
economically it's too rich to be prime
minister he doesn't even know how much
money he's got well that's not actually
the part I think the point the dean was
making the other day was that anybody
who's been in business will know that at
first of all Market shifts so you know
things can change and one of the
problems in politics is we we give a
figure on something and it shifts
because the market shifts and sunny
people say we've got to figure wrong
when we haven't it's just these things
shift around not the reality is he is a
successful businessman this is somebody
who grew a business from nothing he has
had failures in his career most good
businessmen I hope and I've run
businesses you've had good business
decisions bad ones the trick is can you
learn from them and grow and the deems
to how we've shown that he can grow a
good business he can deliver for that
business he's done it in government with
a vaccine roll out so successfully and
the Department of Education it's exactly
what I think he's the right person to to
lead our country How concerned are you
though that he might be over promising
he says he's going to pay for all the
taxation cuts by creaming 20 or cutting
let's say 20 off the workings of
government I mean it's that can't work
surely well as you can and look what yes
no it's absolutely cost you know Nadine
will be and we'll be outlining further
details behind the economic policies
over the next few days that we've been
and the team has been focused on doing
his job as education sector and over the
last week or so as Chancellor so you
know all of these things will be
developing over the data but this is
absolutely costed and what he has taken
the decision on is from his experience
that's part of Education where by
cutting and cracking down on waste he
was able to find 20 of savings I've done
this in departments myself as well we
were doing the same at the North Island
office purely on dealing with some
impact on Services no the important
thing is to make sure it is not impacted
so the civil service has grown by almost
a hundred thousand even in the last 12
years so how could you have allowed
business the Departments to get so
flabby then well what happened in the
early days and I I can remember this I
remember at the department of
communities and local government when I
was there we reduced our cost by about
40 as we've gone through breaks and
particularly through the pandemic the
Civil Service itself has grown again
what we've got to do is make sure it's
conservatives and fiscally sensible we
are focused on bearing down on costs but
still delivering those good outputs and
what Nadeem has put absolutely at the
fun is helping people deal with these
challenges that we're seeing around
inflation the big costs that are coming
through energy the big costs are coming
through food price Rises putting more
money in people's pockets so we Bear
Down on inflation whilst helping people
have more money to be able to run their
lives Paul Johnson the director for the
institute for fiscal studies already
slapping him on the risk saying don't be
talking about tax cuts the budget is
where you talk about tax cuts and what
we want to be able to do is be in a
position where we have the deemers prime
minister with a Chancellor will be able
to set out those tax cuts in detail at
about you but I think it is right when
you're running to be lead with the
conservative party when we're in
government you're wanting to be the
Prime Minister and setting out for
people both parliamentary colleagues and
The Wider public that in the dean we
have somebody who understands what
matters to people what people want to
see yes he wants to make sure we're safe
and secure at home and abroad where
we're seeing uh war on our constant with
uh Putin's violent invasion in Ukraine
but also dealing with those day-to-day
issues and I say that means putting more
money in people's pocket because we're
not just for individuals but understand
that businesses create jobs and security
for people that's why I want to make
sure the business can grow and actually
create an environment where businesses
will want to invest even more in the UK
yesterday we did an exclusive uh with
the would-be Prime Minister and he talks
about him being smeared when it comes to
his taxes who's Sumerian well I think
we've seen actually sadly already during
this campaign so it's actually not just
against the dean but some other
candidates as well
candidate well it's well you say hard to
know where these smears come from but
they come from somewhere I know I was
chairman of the conservative party
through the last leadership campaign and
sadly I've sat through a few of these
campaigns over the years going back to
my early days in politics for some
people with my vested interest well I
don't know people will have to draw
their own conclusions on where they
think these things are coming from look
we're focused on actually fighting a
positive campaign showing people what
the team has to offer actually look one
of the strengths of conservative parties
we've got so much talent in the party we
should be focused all of us actually on
talk about what we want to do for our
country and what we want to do for our
party looking at the video there this is
a video that he's put together why do we
need these slick videos well I think
it's one of the things in the mo in the
modern world with social media is giving
us much opportunity for people to see as
much about the candidates as possible
look nadima's put himself out there he's
come and spoken on your show with a a an
interview this week he's very willing to
talk about his policies his background
his ideas all of these issues I think
it's right that we open ourselves up to
challenge we we answer these questions
and show people what we stand for and in
the modern world uh videos and social
media are part of a part of doing that
with colleagues as well as the general
public last Wednesday night what
happened you were stuck the other side
of the North Sea so you couldn't get at
the Irish there I should say so you can
get involved but what was happening in
number 10. like Wednesday was a a long
and difficult day yes I was in Belfast
for for most of the day working in
Belfast and uh came back to see the
Prime Minister had that frustration of
being delayed somewhat but I came back
flew back in went straight to the Prime
Minister and spent some time with him
um on Wednesday night it was I thought
for me it was very difficult you know
this prime minister we've got a an
overwhelming mandate in 2019 I think he
had I understand his uh he knew that he
had the right to to see that third I
think that that mandate uh showed great
promise to us but it wasn't to be the
reality is the Parliamentary party had
taken of Hume
um I outlined that to him and uh and and
he on Thursday took the decision that it
was time for him to to stand down and
give give way to somebody else and
that's why at that point later on later
on Thursday and Friday Nadine and I had
a conversation I think he made the right
decision in running I want somebody to
be prime minister who will drive this
country forward in a positive way and
did you try and withdraw your
resignation and the Prime Minister said
no no
um why don't you want to be prime
minister because I think we've got in
the Demons of Harley somebody who is a
uh a really good man I mean he is a good
man he's somebody who's got a proven
track record I'm very very proud to be
able to support him and work on and run
his campaign with him he's a great
communicator he understands not just
that we need to help people but to help
people in a way that people can
understand and get these messages out
there and get the money to people in a
way that is clear-cut that makes a
difference their lives every day whilst
being also clear that we have a
long-term plan for the wider growth of
our country and the benefit of the
people and their families we are out of
time but I thought for the people of
Northern Ireland I I hope we see
government restored in Northern as
quickly as possible I think that's the
best thing we can do for the stability
of Northern line I hope all the parties
will come together get stolen elected
there's a lot of money in online and
I've got record funds for online I want
to see that spent again to help people
and businesses in Northern Ireland great
to talk to you Mr Lewis thank you very
much indeed for joining us thank you